signori sono tornati su visa il gioco
delle scarpe avevo trovato per terra una
siringa qua e c'era un tipo latifah anzi
che mi perseguita manco foste mia nonna
quando un omaggio vabbè comunque devo
trovare dovrei uscire di qua perché buio
zamparini è buio mi serve un accendino
per favore grazie e anzi doversi prende
anche due pasticche brutto prenderle
però e fa parte del gioco sono le prendi
c'è il tipo valvola quindi prendi le
pastiglie le pastiglie nel caso non vi
ricordiate servono perché se non le
prendi succedono
tu puoi mettere le cantine sono non lo
sapevo vabbè comunque pia tempo stai nel
buio è più la tua sanità va a farsi
[ __ ] quindi rimaniamo poco nel buio
grazie molto bene siamo trovati già in
un punto abbastanza carino ma c'è gesù
perché devo andare esattamente adesso
allora o la gara shrum qui la chiave del
garage il garage l'ho visto prima e
orribile
però mi sa che è l'unica parte dove
posso andare perché non so dove andare
sempre
la stanza dei progressi questa non puoi
entrare quando può trarre qualche brutto
gioco
marcello giochi a vedere più cioè brutta
faccenda
vabbè siamo partiti da un minuto di
servirebbe capire cosa devo fare bene
nel caso non si fosse capito sono
arrivato in una parte un po difficile da
dal voglio più fare youtube ora calmi
fatemi andare o la chiave del garage
andiamo nei garage l'ultima volta non è
finita bene però devo andare per forza
l'impresa non vado mi fai controllare
abbastanza dei progressi senza che è
stata una mini saltimbocca si so che
cos'è vista sei volte grazie state molto
bene qua dovrebbero comparire degli
oggetti mamma non li faccio progressi
nel gioco che non ho fatto
garage room o l'ultima volta che sono
entrato qui dentro ho fatto una fine
veramente orribile si accende la luce
sanità a posto chiudi la porta allora è
pieno di lampadine quindi prendiamo
si si lo so cosa servono le lampadine
madonna non mi devi insegnare come
camminare lo so posso mettere la
lampadina alla stanza tipo qua c'è una
lampadina cosa per te nelle lampadine
non c'è un lampada ma qua c'è la luce la
mia sanità in questa stanza scende anche
se la a ok ok ok è posto a posto quindi
laddove non le luci non si accendono
posso metterla io molto bene ecco qua
dentro non ci entrerei molto volentieri
però entriamo qui neanche qua dentro ci
si ritrova in sola parte devo entrare
per forza in una lista 2 la mia vita fa
così schifo va bene figurati acceso o
dove siamo ok hanno fatto il giro è
talmente grossa sta a casa che fa i giri
e non te ne accorgi vabbè quindi qua si
entra nel garage vabbè di qualche cosa
serve sempre più in basso molto contento
di questa cosa
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
è chiusa come si è chiusa era prima cioè
palle via via sono qua sono qua sono qua
sono qui sono qui sono qui c'e la luce
c'è la luce c'è la luce tranquilli
datemi delle pillole prima che arrivi il
demonio ammazzarmi gesù aiutami ti prego
no le pillole possiamo andare via da
questo posto demoniaco andare via di qua
aprile aprire la porta noè che è strano
che non puoi aprire la porta a cena c'è
il demonio qua sul soffitto nuovo visto
che porta a questa stanza va bene messo
oggi un cenino metti metti via è figure
avevo l'inventario pieno dov'è che stava
del coso del soffitto
non vedo no no non si accende non sia
dai apri apri dai ragazzi sul serio
halloween è un po ecco la lista per via
via via via via via via via via via via
via via hanno aperto una discoteca qua
sotto che è successo c'è una porta rossa
ma non era rossa sta porta primo ok no
no no no no no no no no non ha presenti
entri nel posto più brutto del mondo
forse l'inferno c'era la cucina lì c'era
la cucina è sì e ci va bene cioè non va
bene in realtà però chi se ne frega
piove fa schifo tutto ma non c'è più la
casa è carino questo che si è alzato
alle 3 di notte per andare a girare per
casa che si ritrova in amazzonia
in mezzo ai pupazzi proprio un gioco
simpatico so come ho fatto a non
scoprirlo prima di andarci salve sono io
oddio questo è quello di toy story solo
luci illusi lucia stanno traducendo
luiss in luce sono lussi
ciao lucy televisore rispondeva bene voi
essendo amico lusi alla radio
esce dal televisore dal televisore un
qualcosa
lucy si incazza la cosa prende la casa
sull'albero ce l'ha messa nella casa
sull'albero quindi lo si dovrebbe dove
passare qui in teoria è un qualcosa è
uscita dal televisore ha preso lucy la
messa in questa casa sull'albero
poi il resto non ho ben capito però
vabbè ma forse c'è qualcosa dietro
cosi ecco la eccola pick up che figata
che ci sono le cose dietro gli oggetti
va bene usiamo la piccola chiave per
aprire il cosino qua manova lui si
drogata a lui si era quella che aveva
dato la siringa prima ho capito che però
si è materializzata con la data è
comunque ok
si prova parla più normale non ho capito
se per te
no siamo ritornati in casa non ho capito
cioè non credo di aver capito no no dai
ti prego ti prego ti prego ti prego non
qui tutto piuttosto nel non qui però dai
sì vabbè dai rami aveva riportato qua ma
sii serio il punto che odio di più
cosa è successo qua cosa succede tutto
buio prima non era così buio va beh
posso uscire dal suo gioco maledetto
nella stanza dei progressi è aumentato
ma perché è diventato tutto buio che
cuoce alle luci prima delusi non sono
simpatico non è questa è la stanza del
progresso c'è niente continua a non fare
progressi nonostante vado avanti nel
gioco non faccio proprio ok problema che
non so dove devo andare adesso non lo so
lusi provandole nella stanza o che se
era un vaso lusi apri veloce perché c'è
la sanità che fa schifo
ecco demonio morto si è aperta questa
ragazzi non ho pin neanche una luce è
cascata la polaroid mondo mi sono pagato
in mano puoi aprire la porta va beh sono
morto sala morto ok sono morto sono
morte sulla morte sono morto
porta chiusa a chiave lo rientrare
dall'altra parte in teoria però mi sa
che mi ammazzano prima ma non fa niente
e ci provo lo stesso jolo
ace sapevo che dovevo entrare dalla
parte opposta non ce l'ho fatta
vabbè mi ha fatto ripartire da qui da te
esattamente da questo punto ma porca
vacca e ho bisogno di pillole non so le
pillole è quello che mi salva sono e la
stanza di lucy sono nella stanza i russi
sono qua sono qua sono qua cosa c'è apri
apri però c'è e quanto tempo
che palle dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
dai dai dai passa ci passa in mezzo in
mezzo passa in mezzo passa in mezzo
veloce veloce via via di qui via aprì la
porta non me ne frega niente pia
no dai aperto
ho appena aperto e sono gabbie di
uccelli mi dai delle pillole per favore
non ce l'ho da da sei anni
gesù perché dai va bene saltami addosso
tanto so che uscirà quando lo so esci
dai fammi vedere a li devo aprire tutti
è divertente
[ __ ] di morire devo morire mare
l'inter sa che è un gioco e non sono
capace le cazzate
l'oscurità e annoiata di giocare ai
giochi per bambini
guarda non me ne frega niente direi che
possiamo concludere qua ragazzi
vado in pausa perché ne ho bisogno avevo
23 anni quando iniziato sto gioco poi
adesso non 45 però fa niente spero mi
sia piaciuto come se vi è piaciuto certo
momento non mi piace continuare il
proprio business contento di averlo
questo gioco sul mio canale quando
scoprono your ore sempre un bel periodo
dell'anno cose se vi è piaciuto 50 mi
piace anche verità tramanda da schizzare
siete scegliamo alla prossima vita da
ragazzi
[Musica]